your shake up in the school district
tonight as the board of trustees voted
to terminate superintendent dr jesus
jarrah so that vote came after hours of
public comment public discussion and
just one of two contentious items on the
agenda tonight sasha loftis is live
tonight with an update on this still
developing story
denise and bryan tonight was nothing
short of explosive as the board of
trustees voted to fire superintendent dr
jesus jarrah now the motion passed four
to three with trustees cavazos cepeda
ford and guzman voting yes in hours
before dozens lined up for public
comment to voice their opinions of dr
jarrah several people were removed for
disruptions an argument in the lobby
even led to some security concerns as
well now once that vote was complete dr
dara read a strong statement gathered
his things and left the room
my focus on student achievement
and well-being has never and will never
waver in my career
unfortunately
a majority of this board
did not share the same vision
for this community and the children
will suffer because of it
now the other major motion on tonight's
agenda was whether to strip linda
cavazos of her title as board president
there was a separate vote filed there to
table that motion that passed five to
one as one of the trustees left for the
night linda cavazos actually voted
against that so that will not be
revisited unless one of the board
members that voted for it brings votes
to bring it up again so again she will
remain board president for now now back
out here live we did reach out to ccsd
to ask whether dr jarrow will be paid
out for the remainder of his contract we
have not yet heard back on that the
board meeting is still happening right
now public comment has started up again
stay with 8 news now for the very latest
online and on air tomorrow morning for
the latest as this develops reporting
live sasha loftis live local now
sasha thanks for that and keep in mind
that dr jarrah was the third
superintendent to oversee what is the
fifth largest school district in the
last decade he took over for pat
garkowski and before him dwight jones
all of them also contracts not renewed